good buddy of mine was at my wedding I
love this man and he's Jeremy shaft from
ESPN how are you Jeremy hey I'm good you
bet and I just figured you know what I
wanted to reach out to you I know you
were at Game six physically there Game
six of the 1986 World Series and you you
interviewed Bill Buckner several times
what is your thought what goes on in
your mind when you when you heard Bill
Buckner had passed yesterday Jeremy well
I was his wife Jodi called me to tell me
and I got to know Bill and Jodi I guess
was 13 years ago on the 20th anniversary
wouldn't still agreed to do a piece free
SPN about the anniversary you know and
his thinking about everything that had
happened of course Jodi was part of it
and we began as an 11 on the 25th
anniversary and much had changed between
those six and 11 he you know come back
to Boston he's been part of a ceremony
there you know they they had won another
World Series and he was in a different
place mostly about the events of 1986 in
the aftermath and we just stayed you
know we hadn't stayed in constant touch
or constant communication but I had
heard last year that that he was gravely
ill and Jodi and I had been in touch and
you know of course we weren't gonna
report anything you know without her her
blessing if you will to go forward but
she knew that I you know was interested
in Bill and that I felt you know a lot
of affection for him and for her and so
she wanted me to know and she wanted me
to share the family statement with
everyone about you know about his death
and you know so I was just sad and I
think like so many people were because
if you knew Bill and I knew him just a
little but you know in our business you
know you might not spend a lot of time
with somebody but you kind of develop a
connection because you're asking them
about their most intimate thoughts and
the most important moments in their
lives and
he was just a great guy he was uh he was
a lovable guy he was a funny guy he was
a great teammate he was someone who you
know a man of great dignity and honor
and I just I just thought the world of
him and so like anybody who felt for him
and nobody nobody should die that way
with that disease and because I knew
bill and you know it's upsetting
Jeremy shap here on the Richardson show
what do you think his legacy is Jeremy
well I think the legacy really is of
someone you know we know he was a great
baseball player you know I'm sure you've
already got over all the numbers you
know more than 2700 hits in a batting
title and you know a four-decade player
I mean you know one of the guys there's
certainly a lot of guys in the Hall of
Fame weren't as good as Bill Buckner and
so this legacy is a great baseball
player but I think more than anything
else it's as someone who overcame and
demonstrated strength of character in
the face of this tremendous adversity
which he didn't even understand you know
the ramifications of it when it happened
in October 1986 I mean you know one of
the things you know there was shocking
to him you know he goes back to his
locker after the game is over
and he doesn't understand why
everybody's around him he you know he I
mean he understood it some extent but he
thought like okay the game was tied
we've got Game seven tomorrow night
ended up being two nights later because
of rainout it was already tied I made an
error we're moving on well you know why
is this the end of the world why is this
you know some kind of catastrophe and I
don't think he was ever able to really
process that you know rich just in the
last couple hours I rewatched
a piece I'd done on the 25th anniversary
and you know he was talking about I said
when did you first realize that you know
this was something that was going to you
have to carry this burden and he said
you know it was a couple days after the
World Series ended and one of the
Booker's on one of the big talk shows
called him he didn't say which one
instead to Mike are you okay you know
how are you doing he's like what are you
talking about
you know it's an air / there was an
error it was a physical error to which
as we know are more excusable than than
mental errors in the field so you know
and then the anger and the resentment
and moving out of the Northeast because
you know there were incidents with fans
not just directed at him but even in his
four-year-old son you know Jodie talked
about that and the peace his wife
so his legacy is a great baseball player
who demonstrated this tremendous
character and grit in the face of this
adversity and did not allow it to
embittered him what was it like to be
around him and Mookie Wilson at the same
time Jeremy I was I was not with both of
them at the same time our tremendous
producer Ben Houser was at the signing
that element of the piece so you know
I've been with Mookie separately about
it and you know that's that's something
you know that I think is a really nice
element of this story how they were
drawn together and of course it's very
reminiscent in a way of the relationship
that Ralph Branca had with Bobby
Thompson my dad as you know you know was
close with both those guys really close
with both of them and one of the things
that brought him great pleasure work in
this business over several decades was
you know bringing Ralph Branca and Bobby
Thompson together for dinner at Rao's
one night and as a kid who is a Brooklyn
Dodgers fan you know who you know was
devastated yet he was 15 years old and
51 when Bobby at the homerun you know to
be to develop relationship with Ralph
Branca and we Bobby Thompson them
together and of course then there's that
connection as you know Ralph Branca zs--
son-in-law for the last 45 plus years
has been Bobby Valentine who is Bill
Buckner's oldest friend in baseball so
you know those are Branca Thompson
Mookie Buckner they weren't in the same
place for all those years you know Ralph
and Bobby both in New York so they
didn't had the same degree of connection
but it was nice to see them develop that
friendship do you think the Red Sox
winning not just a World Series but
multiple ones made anything easier for
Buckner
last few years yeah you know I I mean I
think I think you know it certainly made
it easier for the fans I don't think it
made a difference to him I think you
know the thing that bill said it is
quiet way and the Jodi said in our
pieces in her you know in her in her way
as someone defensive for her husband
someone always protecting him was we
didn't have anything to be forgiven for
you know we had to forgive the fans we
had to forgive the people who were tough
on us about this who made his life
miserable I made him a pariah and and
eventually they got to a point where
they could forgive she said the thing
that bothered her when they went back to
Fenway the first time I think it was
Inouye was after they'd won that second
World Series was you know people were
saying you know we've forgiven you there
were signs of the fans forgiving you I
was like forgiving us for what we
forgive you it is just amazing Jeremy I
mean where does this rank just in terms
of all the stories that you've seen
you've covered your dad exposed you to
when he was alive and you were you know
missing all this really rich so it is
you know there's a poignancy to it and
there's a sadness to it and there is
consequence in terms of the lives that
were affected by this one plane this one
moment which you know you got to put
yourself back you know it's 1986 it's
been 68 years the curse all of that you
know the that one play and it's made
more so by the fact that Bill Buckner
was this great player a guy who gave
everything and I'll tell you sir I don't
think I've ever told this story on TV or
the radio or anywhere but I was at the
game with my father I was a senior in
high school and we're coming down in an
elevator and sometimes it's like he
can't remember did this really happen
but I swear this really happened we're
coming down in the elevator from the
level at which we've been watching the
game the sports channel box and you know
we're going down to a clubhouse my dad's
got do
some interviews and somehow we end up on
the elevator I think it was just for
people I think it was Ray Flynn who's
mayor Boston became the US ambassador of
the Vatican it's my father myself you
know high school senior and Bart
Giamatti Bart Giamatti was the president
of the National League at this point not
the Commissioner baseball the president
the National League and the team
representing his league in the World
Series has just pulled off one of the
most remarkable comebacks to stay alive
in the World Series that we've ever seen
fashion the history baseball and he was
cursing McNamara I think he used
expletive and said lank McNamara where
was Stapleton this is the prisoner
National League so immediately there was
that you know react she wasn't blaming
Buckner but it's it's a moment I guess
you have to be from New England you have
to be from Boston to understand what it
meant in that moment and Bob Ryan said
it I think best in in the piece we did
in 2011 he said look you know for Red
Sox fans who had you know suffered for
so long it felt like Bill Buckner has
done this to them personally which is
crazy but it's an emotional fan response
and it was a Makura comeback to be
embraced whether he felt he needed to be
embraced or not all of that made it a
rich story and I was very privileged
just to get to know Bill Buckner a
little bit yeah I mean you mentioned
he's Stapleton being Dave Stapleton who
would have been the defensive
replacement for for Buckner last one for
you Jeremie second most hits in the 70s
and 80s combined second only to Pete
Rose third lowest strikeout rate since
1950 with Tony Gwynn and Nellie Fox
being the only others he never struck
out more than two times in a single game
if Buckner fields that ball and steps on
the bag do you think he'd be in
Cooperstown
today no I don't I mean I think you
could make a case for Bill Buckner but I
don't think you know the standards that
we have now in terms of accumulating
numbers and I haven't looked at it so I
could be wrong rich but my impression
was if I went back and looked carefully
at it he would fall just short he'd be
in that category that falls just short
but as I said there are certainly
players in the Hall of Fame weren't as
good as Bill Buckner but but I don't
think that that that prevents him from
being the cool
Jeremy you're the man you are the best
there really is nobody like you every
single time I talk to you I miss talking
to you so - I'm sure soon as you'd want
to send my best to you and Jocelyn the
rest of your family
there you go you got it Jeremy shop here
in the Rich Eisen show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on Direct TV for free on be our live
or download the Rich Eisen show app